I'm glad I want to wake up-I
suddenly collapse in front of you I
'm not surprised
[Music]
You feel uncomfortable-
I don't know that you're Son Goku-I think it's
easy to decide  What's wrong, the strange tone is pretty,
so let's take a look at your own face.
[Music]
ni When
there is a filthy girl, a filthy girl appears.
The player who is linked to the spirit of the super warriors and adjusted to approach the core of the story consisting of all three episodes.
It's up to you
how to proceed
[Music]
I wonder what you taste like The
key is the mysterious scientist Kidney Human 21
Resurrected No. 16
Their purpose is full Ipyon Patty is Son Goku Good link  See
here to do vale Say Padada Nyohaseyo
Ah ah ah
That power Because the princess without permission is also in Safe
Ice
[Music]
[Applause]